we had always believed in writing the
upbeat optimistic anthem songs of
inclusion telling you that you could do
it too a lot of that you know it really
was our calling card and it was good for
me to never show too much of that hurt
or vulnerability probably because I
didn't want in my slice of your life to
let you down and I remember writing a
record like what the blaze of glory
record and I was hiding behind Billy the
Kid because it was a soundtrack written
for a film and I just took the voice it
really liked it
very well on all ten of those songs and
and so I was hiding behind things the
thing about this house is not for sale
is out of great pain comes great art and
so there was a lot to say and these last
three years have not been easy even
since I saw you last
we went off and did that dozen shows and
and it was it was tough coming back to
complete the this album all of that was
fuel for songs it's part of the reason
it has been such a tough year was the
department years three years yeah blink
your eyes was three years was the
department reporter so we're cheese and
blue yeah yeah I am part of it you know
one element of it uh it was you know
that it was a the record contract and
you know what was going on with me in
the company until we kissed and made up
and a business dealing that I was really
you know put everything I had
- that we're all kinds of just things
that shook the tree a bit you know but
you come through them in you and you
move on that's that's what life's about
moving forward I remember in our last
discussion you you definitely aren't
somebody to look back you're you're a
move forward personality with I mean has
to be part of the reason that you've
stayed so relevant as a band for so long
perhaps I I just I was never want to
rest on our previous successes
not that I'm success driven anymore
maybe like I used to be as a kid or I
should freely admit that I was in fact
you know as a younger guy um but I don't
think that I need to sit around and go
did I ever tell you the time that I know
I've done it I've done it it's spoken I
don't I don't need to tell you what I've
done did you expect for Richard to reach
out via social media to congratulate you
with no other way you know I mean
there's no ill will you know the guy
quit one day never showed up for work it
must have felt nice though to have an
old friend and it there's no girl will
hear you don't like I said um the way
that that he did it we appreciate it
did he did it did it you know it's
evident that he's moved on in his life
one day he woke up and decided he didn't
want to be in the band anymore and then
in truth look I've said the same thing
over and over again being in a rock band
it's not a life sentence right and just
because he chose not to come back that
was his prerogative end of story
you know we never had a fight I goes to
show you now that I've been vindicated
right I mean there was never a fight was
never ever fighters never bound money
has never been nothing he just walked
out one day on the band and that was it